bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale
tv spéciale championnats du monde à
l'inde
topalov et nous allons suivre
aujourd'hui la huitième partie pour
cette huitième partie nous recevons pour
deuxième fois pour ce championnat du
monde nicolas magic giffard salonique au
volant stéphane alors maître
international
on ne redira jamais assez double
champion de france et oui 18,80 ta plus
grande fierté il ya très longtemps mais
bon ça reste on est sur la liste a été
sur la liste et sur l'a10 à l'internât
sur le palmarès quoi surtout que je
crois que d'ailleurs ça me fait penser
que c'est assez récent mais là la ffe a
récupéré le palmarès complet des
champions de france et il n'allait pas
c'est en amont ne l'avait pas et il
adorait paris chercheurs n'ont ni
championnat de france ils ont eu du vent
ils ont récupéré pour le mettre sur
internet tout pour avoir le palmarès
complet
non mais leur manque évident at par
exemple leur manquer les serbes des
dates ancien nom il ya eu un championnat
de france amateur en 1903 ouais
par exemple voilà qui n'avait pas été
bien répertoire et les malades mais il
n'était pas vraiment officiel non plus
un mais oui mais
mais bon ça compte donc qu'il manquait
des trucs alors donc voilà maintenant
ils ont tous avec boot vignes qui est
toujours recordman il ya trois joueurs
boudeville reisen et bacrot et que s'il
attend macro poupou fumay bacrot
pratiquement à chaque championnat de
france qui jouent ils le gagnent mais il
a l'air de se moquer totalement du fait
d'avoir un record historique a annoncé
un record ça compte mais oui bah oui non
peut-être que plus tard et en mûrissant
ils s'apercevraient c'est important de
rentrer dans l'histoire
alors c'est bien que tu parles de
maquereaux parce que pour la première
fois depuis
parce que tu es aussi donc écrivain
best-seller on peut dire qu'un écrivain
écrit un best seller en baisse riders
pour les échecs devant les échecs avec
une nouvelle édition du guide des échecs
dont l'addition précédentes remontées à
93 et maintenant évidemment 93e et par
acro puisqu'il était à peine son deuil
avec akram n'y avait pas kramnik le nous
le révélait en 94 voilà et 4,4 et
surtout qu'à 14e champion du monde celui
qui a battu kasparov évidemment on va
retrouver kramnik bacrot et tous les
joueurs modernes depuis 1993 avec les
champions du monde les parties et c'est
dans le nouveau guide des échecs traité
complet alors qui est quand même
magnifique alors c'est la bible des
échecs en français évidemment alors
première édition de ce livre sur
l'histoire du jeu d'échecs
on va dire la fabuleuse histoire du jeu
d'échecs 178 nouvelles éditions 93
augmenté de tout de la technique c'est
un livre d'initiation toute la technique
iat l'initiation évidemment pour
apprendre à jouer mais tout l'aspect
historique moi j'ai appris le jeu
d'échecs avait une histoire en fait moi
c'est ça qui m'a passionné les vacances
c'est l'histoire du jeu d'échec j'ai
trouvé sa meilleure fabuleux qui est un
jeu comme ça où on peut retrouver les
meilleurs champions du monde même rue
lopez on peut considérer qu'en 15ème
cheikh xvième siècle je sais plus quelle
est la date exacte c'était le meilleur
joueur du monde donc on va on va
retrouver un jeu sont 1500 ans avec
toute une histoire des grands joueurs
d'échecs les philidor on va retrouver
les italiens on va retrouver tout ça
toute cette histoire l'un puis ça passe
en revue la rivalité pour la place de le
champion du monde ou alors là la
rivalité pour la pression peut nous
alors au niveau des individus qui au
niveau des nations
on va trouver laisse les voitures
l'italie au niveau politique au niveau
pendant la guerre froide carré
la guerre froide avec les russes et
c'est donc toute histoire du jeu
d'échecs évident tout une partie
initiation du débutant jusqu'à un joueur
confirmé
donc vous pouvez apprendre à jouer aux
échecs avec ce magnifique client qui est
l'équivalent le s'il voulait ainsi que
le pdi l'universalisme et pour les
échecs
donc c'est nicolas giffard et à l'aim
viennent à bhl qui signe aussi pour un
quart du bouquin tout des problèmes
d'échec alors magnifique aussi pour les
chercheurs pour les détectives des
échecs on les esthètes pour les esthètes
et donc l'histoire toute l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs avec tous les champions du
monde événement officiel mais ce aussi
de l'histoire avait l'histoire de ces
fameux champions j'ai envie de dire d
époque fabuleuse
on va dire ça vous imaginer mille cinq
cents ans d'histoire du jeu d'échecs il
s'en est passé des choses est évidemment
aussi l'initiation est alors toutes les
parties gagnées toutes les victoires des
championnats du monde officiel c'est à
dire qu'on va retrouver les victoires 2
nuls et l'histoire de la sq r2 pas
capable en k2 fischer de classe termine
avec le match amical en 2001 2009
krainik attendons qu'il faudra
évidemment non seulement de 2008 pardon
de 2008 il faudra compléter sa
collection avec sap et en plus comme si
revisitée il ya une réécriture il ya une
révision comme ça historique
d'ailleurs tu l'appelles l'explosion
depuis 80 ans ce qu'ils savaient et la
dissidence de kasparov et short
dissidence du classement après
évidemment mais il y aura sans doute une
autre édition bat plus tard puisqu'il
faudra commenter ce match
un an topalov alors mais j'en reparle
dans la finition
le nouveau guide des échecs présente
toutes les librairies étant sur internet
partout c'est absolument avoir dans sa
bibliothèque si on est passionné
d'échecs alors à lanquetot palop nicolas
matches où tu as un favori puisque c'est
en ami le joueur le plus punchy c'est
topalov surtout au fil du match
c'est lui qui est physiquement et le
plus fort et il l'a montré dans ces
dernières années les fins de tournoi il
les joue beaucoup mieux que les autres
joueurs de son niveau il a les joueurs
gagner les tournois qu'il a gagné
récemment dans les dernières rondes
alors moi j'ai le sentiment quand je
regarde jouer topalov que c'est un
joueur qui joue tout c'est parti à fond
il fit jamais nulle de complaisance et
je pense que sur le circuit actuellement
si le joueur qui me rappelle le plus
kasparov en fait oui il est toujours à
la recherche de l'attak en mai mais ils
n'aiment pas trop défendre il n'est pas
très patients sont des fausses et qu'il
est souvent trop optimistes et ils des
ouvertures un répertoire confectionner
mijoter je dirais par son jeune seconde
ans chez par innove avec des variantes
très aigu comme on a vu dans la septième
partie où il a sacrifié une pièce oui et
donc par conséquent il est toujours à la
recherche de l'initiative toujours
traversé par des risques comme kasparov
comme kasparov peut-être que il a une
connaissance générale des échecs moindre
il ya un peu moins bien préparé un peu
moins fort en finale tous un peu moins
bien mais effectivement dans la même
lignée des joueurs d'attaqué à liqin que
kasparov
voilà donc et un homme qui est toujours
un joueur magnifique évidemment quand
même dont on peut signaler la la la la
ce style là on est plus difficile à
définir on voit chez lui un talent
naturel énorme puisqu'il lui permet de
jouer à toute vitesse c'est parti ce qui
est rarissime
mais aussi il a un peu ce défaut du
joueur qui joue vite c'est à dire qu'on
a l'impression parfois que il
approfondit pas votre association
un peu trop facile qu'il arrivait trop
trop facilement et puis alors il a aussi
donc n'a peut-être pas été assez assez
assez de d'opposants
en 95 il a rencontré kasparov en finale
du championnat du monde non officiel
mais sans et à ce moment là le deuxième
joueur du monde on vous le dire à peu
près avec karpov et a perdu bon on a
quand même après avoir tenu pendant plus
de la moitié du match mais il s'est
écroulé à la fin alors j'ai peur que
dans ce match aussi un écroulement parce
que il a un moins d'énergie s'explique
évidente et puis il faut le gari je vous
chie cette opa voilà il jouissait
topalov on sait pas est ce que oscillé
dans des conditions optimum pour jouer
peut-être il ya des choses qu'on ne sait
pas trop ce qui est dérangé dans son
sommeil on sait pas il ya tout
est-ce que les bulgares voilà le yaourt
bulgare elle doit terminer à la filière
bulgare
on sait pas alors match anand topalov
évidemment alors donc là donc on est sur
la huitième partie
donc on y va topalov à l'eiblen alors
uni mené au score
oui toujours d'un point on se demande
vraiment comment il va faire pour
revenir parce que un an de joue avec une
solidité extrême avec les noix oui parce
qu'on va rappeler quand même que très
vite que anne on a perdu la première
alors c'était quand la brousse parce
qu'il a joué à la défense grünfeld sur
laquelle apparemment il n'était pas
aussi bien préparés que topalov et puis
c'est une position trop complexe oui qui
convient très bien à topaloff est un peu
moins bien à lui surtout quand il a pas
trop approfondi leurs ancêtres mais
après les revenus que si elle a gagné la
deuxième et la quatrième de falla les
tribus lors du voile à gland à la cram
unique a résumé dans le titre cramique
allemand de lui donc il a un style plus
caméléon il peut changer attaquer
défendre on sait pas trop où est plus
universel suivant son humeur du jour
ça dépend comment comment il se sent
alors on y va tous parlent pas les
blancs il est mené d'un point si la
huitième partie je vous rappelle que le
match joué en douce donc il ya quand
même la pression maximale maintenant sur
ces partira ce que quatre parties pour
topalov pour revenir au score alors on y
va des 4 il joue aussi au 4 mai un peu
moins souvent que d 4d saint jean ce
match se cantonne donc aux purs dame
voix lors des scènes déjà ça sera pas
une grande fan
il a joué qu'à la première et puis
finalement il a abandonné tout de suite
granby dan c4 c4 c6 donc là on est sur
une défense la 1e slave ici avec ce
fameux coup serait solide alors la fois
c'est très solide sap comptes solides de
dessins et puis ça empêche d'en fermer
le fou puisque ce fou peut envisager de
sortir en 20-25 c'est la défense
c'est pratiquement la défense la plus
populaire dans les tournois open chez
les jeunes maintenant et la défense
qu'on voit le plus fréquemment qui est
extrêmement solide donc et qui a été
beaucoup pénalisés ces derniers temps
avec des nouvelles variantes notamment
liés ou petit coup à 7 à 6 alors on y va
car élèves trois cavaliers m6
normalement sur un carnet calais c3 donc
la dépense et 4 évidemment c'est
toujours une menace alors oui là et
c'est un tournant dans l'ouverture on
appelle slave
effectivement la suite qui découlent de
dépenser cavaliers avant d'aller jouer
eux cet os 6 si on appelle smith a remis
cela c'est pas la même idée
ouais voilà donc là on prend le pion
hélas lors les blancs peuvent envisager
de jouer eux quatre direct service à
ganvié sacrifices ce plan puisque les
noirs le protège tout de suite ça
s'appelle le gambit cela justement là où
alors ce que joue un an d'ici qui est
une autre option auprès des princes et
4,6 jouer à 4 donc empêché le coup b5
pendant le couple est simple et donc on
va reprendre enfin le ce que je vous
pardonne topalov un haka on va reprendre
pour ses quatre plus tard après avoir
joué soit 4 soit 3 4 3 par le fonds soit
cas valeo 5 ou alors bien sûr aussi que
marine le pen et prendre le pion ces
quatre là on va leur prendre donc on
empêche cette consolidation centrale
donc fou et 5
alors on ad'autres khouya fou j'ai capté
ici aussi j'ai les cavaliers à 6 aussi
qu'ils existent et puis aussi jouer fou
g4 ou cavaliers à six sans doute avec
l'idée de leur revenir
oui aussi ceux ci existent dans ces sept
voire en b 4 puisque la b4 et unique à
ce sympathique maintenant qu'on a collé
blanc joue à quatre pour venir en
décimant voilà il ya plein de
possibilités faux f5 donc là en fait en
boule classique et on retrouve la même
partie finalement que les parties
3 5 exactement et on va voir que c'est
exactement
alors il ya cabello 5 donc l'autre coup
classique ce3 évidemment le reprend dans
ces cas pas avec le faux alors faut être
sain l'idée c'est qu'on empêche
évidemment les blancs de jouer eux
quatre avec l'idée d'aller prendre aussi
le pion c4 est d'abord un gros centre de
pions en juin soit officiel qu'on
empêche sa donc sur e3 était possible si
on joue le pion d'une seule case et on
prend le mail ait choisi c'est l'autre
variante à l'intérieur un peu 6 et f3
voilà c'est ça l'idée de kallio 5 c'est
de jouer f3e 4 à prendre un gros espace
au centre et puis posé le problème sous
huy qui va se retrouver enfermé à l'est
le roi voilà alors été isolés du champ
de bataille réaction logique là des
noirs c5
alors non mais c'est pas le couple le
plus principal la variante la plus
habituelle est la plus violente
d'ailleurs ces fourbes et 4 soup éclater
le 4e 4 quand même fou prend le terrain
et on sacrifie de vous puis on prend en
pillant et hier on profite du célèbre
cavalier est cloué ici et on a pris deux
pions food et 2 alors comme ça
ou encore je me fous de l'homme prend
des cats et très violente troisième pion
cavaliers prendre 400 dame prend 1,4
échec échec vraiment eu deux fous prend
des deux échecs on reprend des deux
français est ré analysés il ya en
général les noirs je vous donne des sacs
maintenant les noirs ont trois pions
contre une pièce si je ne m'abuse avec
trois ou quatre pions de 1 2 3 4 lyon
puisque les autres pions on leur en
leurs homologues est considéré comme
légèrement avantageux pour les blancs
alors regardez tous les camps gauche
soit en plus c'est quand même considéré
comme entachées ça fait quand même
quatre pions pour la pièce j'ai beaucoup
aimé il s'avère il s'avère que les
pièces blanches sont mieux mobiliser
dans la colonne des récents jeux plus on
va mettre le roi ans et 200 da et puis
on va ramener l'argent
ouais seront plus rapidement je viens du
jeu il ya du jeu très vite bon enfin
c'est quand même c'est une autre
variante beaucoup plus sauvage que c'est
de jouer ma partie la voix la f3c 5
alors c'est celle qu'il vende plus
positionnelle et qui est celle ci voilà
je contre attaque je profite du fait que
les blancs de jouer le 4 mai que
maintenant qu'on a joué f3 bas il faut
jouer quatre pour affaiblir la casse des
cadres échangé ce pion très vite avec la
dame qui fait pression mais elle edouard
accepte d'avoir un fou qui est enfermé
allait droit au cap fréhel 6,6 alors là
de retour avec un fou un peu en dehors
du de la bataille on l'a déjà signalé si
évidemment 7,7 clone de pions muselle le
fouet puis dans les autres partis dans
les parties 3,5 topalov en a même
profité pour jouer h4 menacé d'aller
carrément de prendre le fou g6 avec h5
alors si les noirs résolvent ce problème
comme un homme n'a démontré dans les
parties précédentes justement pourri le
problème de ce fou et bien ils ont un
jeu acceptable mais pas vraiment mieux
que le nul alors en continu pour voir la
position clé fouet trois donc la prison
des cats tranquillement et adam croit on
n'hésite pas de rentrer dans une finale
et après alors on verra on continue les
coûts parce que si les mêmes couple est
parti trois et cinq et on va commenter
la position clé ici d'un prend des
quatre fous prend des quatre cavaliers
f17 voilà je propose effectivement un
échange ici au sens alors je mets ce
cavalier sans doute parce que le noir
veulent peut-être prendre le 5 qui
jouent et f6 au sein qui prépare la
sortie d'un big bear aurait le fou j'ai
six pour venir en aide cette mais ça
existe beaucoup de contorsions au noir
pour pouvoir se libérer ce rouge et 6
donc ici prise prise fous ces quatre et
on y est alors ça c'est la position
qu'on a vu dans les parties numéro 3 et
5 est là dans ces deux parties à nantes
avait joué à six et s'en était sorti
relativement il en était sorti assez
bien alors il ya eu deux variantes
topaloff avait joué hkd dans l'es2 et
anand a choisi dans la troisième de
jouer h6 et dans la cinquième de jouer
h5 qui sont les deux coups qui empêche
évidemment h5 prend le fou puisque
évidemment en jouant ce pion on peut
sortir le fou en rage set il a joué ses
deux ces deux possibilités et a réussi
quand même en jouant des jolis coups
c'était quand
évident parce qu'il est sous pression il
a dû analyser que en fait le coup qu'il
a joué tour sévit dans cette partie et
lui donner moins de souffrance mais il
s'est trompé
visiblement il s'est trompé puisque dans
cette partie donc il n'a pas rejoué ses
variantes combien de la voiture s'est
vite c'est pas là alors c'est avant
d'arriver à ce cours on va quand même
rappelé nicolas conte et en championnat
du monde évidemment donc les joueurs
jouent 12 parties et il est classique
dans ces championnats comme on l'a vu
dans les grands matches castard karpov
surtout dons qu'ils en ont fait un
paquet que les joueurs les imac surtout
à les kin contre capable en cas bien sûr
le gambit dame s'était répété 25 fois
sur 31 et les joueurs et 6 pour essayer
de percer la défense adverse et avec
l'idée que s'ils arrivent à percer cette
défense ils ont une victoire
psychologique énorme parce que
l'adversaire n'osera plus la jouer parce
qu'il se dire mince ça passe ailleurs ma
défense a l'air pas bonne et dans ce
cas-là l'angoissent du joueur ces deux
repères donc il va changer mais en
changeant il risque jouer quelque chose
qui connaît moins bien et encore et
perdre aussi donc il ya une espèce de
barrière psychologique on perce et qui
permet de grandes prendre un gros
ascendant en fait oui et ça on ne peut
pas le voir un tour - non non bien sûr
là c'est à dire à zoey l'un d'eux elle
savait rien à voir psychologiquement
parce que les tourangeaux
il ya dix joueurs chacun joue contre les
autres et donc aux chaque partie est
très différent de la psychologie a
beaucoup moins d'un pour voilà alors
qu'en match la psychologie prend une
prépondérance et c'est ça qui fait le
charme des matches oui après on dit
change tout donc là on voit que tout par
l'offre insiste c'est la troisième fois
qu'il joue cette position and on a testé
déjà deux choses pour tenir il a réussi
à tenir et puis là il dit mais elle est
peut-être que topalov à préparer
finalement des nouveautés des choses que
j'ai mal comprises ou que j'ai ou j'ai
vu qu'il y avait des faiblesses dans mon
jeu dans les parties 3 et 5 donc pour
éviter la lah disons-le à l'amélioration
au total of je vais jouer un nouveau
coup et là à nantes joue aux nouveaux
contours suite
bah oui c'est dans ce match c'est
toujours un homme d'ailleurs qui
innovent ils jouent tour s'est vite au
lieu de jouer
c'est ce que la sauce dans la septième
partie qu'on voit là qu'on a vu l'autre
jour pour ses blessés annoncent qu'ils
innovent le premier donc dans le match
voilà ne sera pas l'air de déranger
topaloff alors alors c'est un match
aussi où les spectateurs ne doivent pas
arriver en faire parce que cette partie
les 13 premiers coups ont été débités en
une minute
oui puisqu'il avait déjà joué donnera
donc effectivement on peut vous dire
qu'ils la connaissent
c'est un peu le défaut de ces longs
duels qu'on est parti se répète au
nouveau d ouverture il ya un peu on
s'ennuie un peu dans les premiers coups
puisque ça se passe rien de spécial
exactement et l'a donc garonne a total
of doit trouver un plan intéressant
bah oui va profiter de l'avantagé de
déploiement de ces pièces qui sont
pratiquement tout est sorti tout enjeu
les noirs vous pendant quelques coups
avec une pièce de moins le fou le faut
et suite j'ai six îles et il est
complètement
j'ai la tourache 8 aussi un gros
avantage de sortie de pièces de temps de
développement de mobilisation des pièces
chez les blancs d'un autre côté on se
dit oui mais attention il va changer
surtout b5 contre le cas et des décès
oui mais le roi noir bien que les dames
soit échangé l'enrôlement a quand même
des soucis avec les tours qui vont
arriver sur les color alors il va se
retrouver au centre et en fait on voit
on doivent être pourchassés par les
tours il va y avoir des motifs tactique
les tours blanches vont venir au centre
et vont pouvoir tenter de harceler ce
roi et puis ce fouillis hors jeu parce
que non seulement cela n'est pas sorti
mais celui-là on pouvait surtout bouger
si ce qui pose problème parce qu'il est
bloqué par les pénibles au caire et ça
exige plusieurs coups de perdus pour les
noirs pour le sortir mais là on se dit
bon beh autant prendre quand même la
paire de fou 1 malgré ses désavantages
de développement et ce roi qui va être
au centre il joue à six et la belle et
blanc ne peuvent justifier leur courroux
des scènes quand ronan arzel parce que
si j'enlève le fou c'est vrai que
j'aurais perdu du temps donc il faut
prendre 17 est bon il faut quand même
être costaud parce que non ils donnent
la paire de fou comme 1 alors que dans
les autres partis il avait gardé mais on
peut estimer que le fou noir angers 6
est un peu un gros pions c'est un gros
pions également pu effectivement c'est
un gros pions pour l'instant et dans les
deux parties derrière les deux slave qui
ont précédé tout le problème danone a
été de le libérer et quand il est deux
fois il a réussi à le libérer
il a fallu la cia finul facilement mais
tout le problème effectivement et 2
de compenser l'activité pièces noires
des pièces blanches adverse voilà en
présence d'entrées ce jeu alors ici roy
prendre 17 est la rolls de leur ca on
les a vus dans les autres partis aussi
un moyen classique dans les deux autres
partis à chaque fois les jours de
topalov on ne rend que pas parce que
évidemment c'est une partie le roi peut
être actif
voilà sans le roi et au centre actif et
les tours sont liés de la même façon en
général en europe parce que la dame
adverse est toujours l'un et m leroy au
centre alors que la dame sont là
évidemment c'est dangereux
voilà mais là on voit que bahreïn sera
saura blanc ont regardé le roi blanc
craint rien puisqu'en face évidemment il
n'y a pas de leurs débuts elle a
débouché sur sur la diagonale il reste
pas parce que le foot faso notre côté
donc presque pas y avoir des chèques là
dessus mais pas de cavalier
donc ils risquent absolument rien au
contraire il est très utile au centre
puisqu'il peut protéger la casse d un
pour les tours il peut avoir
voilà les ans le trois protégés sans
valeur de 3 aussi et il peut avoir un
rôle en finale depuis assigné la mission
donc m6 mais voilà ça aussi c'est alors
on se dit quand même salaire plus simple
que dans les parties précédent dans les
pré m6 va le foot a essayé tout de suite
vous voilà et puis le fouet fuite aussi
va pouvoir bouger puisque le pion g7
n'est plus avec le pion g7 nom est
protégé donc ça c'est un coup aussi ce
qu'on a vu dans les autres partis aussi
ouais donc un coup classique mais le
problème d'annoncer qu'il va pas avoir
le temps de continuer logiquement il
n'aura pas le temps on va voir tour hd
reims et voilà et tout de suite les
menaces menace fo prend f6 échec aura
prend un pion et ont fait celle de la
tour ce qui oblige de parer les chèques
et ensuite on a gagné un pur classique
faut enlever le roi c'est obligé et si
les noirs joueurs se trompent 1 jouant
fou des six est une erreur même on joue
au 5 et problème puisque après c'est la
catastrophe
elle prend le 5-fu prendre sert au moins
depuis on a un clouage sur des six est
le seul coup ici ses tours ses six pour
protéger et simplement mais on prend le
plan g7
on a gagné un gros pions dans une finale
surtout qu'on va pouvoir échanger un fou
douala et en initiatives demeurent en
pointe et en plus on maintient aussi ce
qui est fait main avec un gros avantage
même sans doute un avantage décisif ou
quasi décisif alors ton hd est donc ici
donc bien non il peut pas jouer il faut
des six alors il va jouer on doit
enlever le roi et peut pas laisser le
roi qu'on va laisser le roi finlandais
donc là ouais mais du coup il mal
placées sous main parce qu'il empêche
les tours d'être lié ouais on aurait
aimé pouvoir jouer à food et 6 3 au 7 et
mètres la tour il n'a pas le temps
absolument à 5 alors c'est marrant alors
ça c'est pour faire jouer le cavalier
qui n'avaient pas de case et c'est un
coup qu'on a vu dans les autres partis
aussi va s'acquitter de la casse b6
faible à ivry cavaliers infiltré la
malaisie et puis aussi le bain
il y tenir cet accueil il me coincer
pion qui peuvent plus bouger
peut-être qu'il n'avait pas le choix
donc pour bouger déjà mais voilà ça
permet effectivement d'activer le
cavalier par mes 6 alors avant il faudra
de contrôler la casse et 2 sans doute
pour empêcher que la tour adverses
viennent en c2 alors fouet cette balade
est vrai c'est moins bien phu est que ce
sont des six dans les autres partis à on
avait réussi à jouer food et 6 et en
mettant leurs voix aux sénateurs
s'étaient alors ils sont l'idée c'est de
faire wife 7 mai à nantes valant peu cow
palace va l'empêcher et jouer la wii
même un jour henri vii le voilà c'est ça
active toujours software mais surtout
que donc topalov joue faux bessif au v6
et si le roi vient en effet cette salle
est rentré la tour blanche la fameuse
septième rangée
face à la catastrophe le qui ont
bessette tombe clouage lupion 17 et
attaquer si ici on protège pas retombée
8tb ça marche mais simplement jouer fou
à 7
alors on peut même attendre puisque ya
rien pour protéger le 17 on peut d'abord
doublé l'état n'est pas question de
laisser la tour-blanche s'infiltrait sa
septième ce serait une catastrophe email
donkey bd j ai mal quoi oui alors il
trouva une manière quand même de sortir
ces pièces par touré fuite et tours fc
est alors pourquoi la septième rangée
même alors c'était son idée c'est tous
rêvent cette fois fuite ensuite tout est
contrôlé tous rêvent cette fois et suite
et je jouais sans doute tour des 7
derrière j'ai activé mathon mais c'est
un peu long mais le côté bon temps que
vous les blancs vont pas vraiment de
menaces voilà il ya une grosse menace
pas de regret blesse non plus dans le
camp noir soit qu'ils soient attaquable
directement sur le moment ça m'a paru
d'ailleurs une défense contre laquelle
n'y avait pas
l'agression à faire mais là il a trouvé
un coup très simple et très fort c'est
tour c'est un tour assez un tour chez un
simplement parce qu'il veut profiter du
fait que la tour c 8 ne peut pas tenir
tout seul la septième rangée
il allie des cavaliers à 4 et l'idée
c'est de voir les tours d'un fils trois
ans et cette fois en dix-sept de jouer
cavalier à 4 après quoi il ya une tour
blanche qui doit arriver ce que tu
aimerais donc un échange si un échange
de tours en échange et on à la casse et
7 pour la tour on va pouvoir venir ans
et cette attaque et se faire nos pions
c'est pour ça qu'un homme s'est senti
obligé de faire quelque chose ici ne pas
rester passifs
s'il avait joué donc roi f7 n'est pas
bon mais s'il allait jouer ce tour et
cède présume bref séjour pas bon à cause
de tournée voilà s'il avait joué ce tour
f 16 dont on parlait alors il ya le
cookie avaler à 4 qui est très gênant
simplement cavalière 4 à les regarder
avec son vis-à-vis mais voilà vous
l'apprendre on va falloir lâcher une
case tout reprend je menace pour ces
scènes où tour ses buts ou tour c8 et
surtout des six qui possible je peux
quand même je vous trouve ses 8,3 des
scènes tout échec tour
je peux faire échec aussi je peux faire
en échec là je peux en utah je peux
aussi venu en g8
oui puis le fou g6 qui est toujours
enfermé ce fou qui est toujours enfermé
voilà une possibilité alors tu auras
c'est un donc la nôtre se sent obligé de
jouer
alors quand même pu le tenter ça mais
sur mes f5
voilà donc la la il menace d'ouvrir le
jeu pour le fou mais la voilà il arrive
à échanger ici ça libère en plus
l'action de la tour f 8 bon c'est bien
ça fait une faiblesse contre une
faiblesse au centre ce fou devient actif
puisqu'il va attaquer aux quatre que
palop doivent bloquer par où ça qu'il
faut bloquer voilà ils bloquent très
bien et la jolie kunda nantes ce qui
paraît bon puisqu'il joue faux g5 parce
que je sais que c'était intéressant
puisque il s'attaque la tour tap la tour
ça libère le fou voilà ce serait une
grosse faute maintenant pour topalov
d'enlever sa tour en 1 par exemple
européennes ont déjà joué pour rien
voilà moi je pourrais donc il est obligé
de faire flouer 3 il a pas mieux voilà
vous doit pas céder du terrain aux 3
voilà donc fou et 3 donc c'est mieux
voilà maintenant que anne on va faire
une erreur inattendu pour un joueur de
son niveau il a avoué après que voilà
donc là c'est la gaffe il fait une
première gaffe première can aurait pu
lui coûter la partie mais quand même
qu'il va donner un gros avantage à
topaloff alors là donc moment crucial du
match n'ont déjà on a vu qu'il était
quand même un peu en difficulté par
rapport aux parties prenantes où c'était
plus solide
le fait que le roi son enceinte que le
tour soit palier qui n'est pas réussi
vraiment à libérer son jeu il a été
menacé pendant tous les derniers coups
et la série fait une gaffe alors déjà
c'est pas un coup qu'on a envie de jouer
il joue f4 alors non pourquoi on n'a pas
envie de jouer 4 parce que ben on a un
pion qui devient
et surtout en fait il n'a pas vu la
menace des blancs une menace c'est de
jouer cavalier b5 ou cavaliers ou quatre
les douces mais il n'a pas vu voilà il
n'a pas vu cette menace mais qu'est ce
qu'il aurait pu faire ici donc il aurait
pu tenter alors donc ça ça va et là ils
ont ils auraient [ __ ] de jouer le roi
recettes peut-être rien pour vous
changer les fous ça oui et shepard ont
échangé les foules n'aurait pu échanger
devez vous et après roy prendre trois
maintenant peut-être poussé à toi est-ce
quatre échecs pourquoi pour libérer le
fou comme ça le foot mais à des cases un
encas des changes des touba il aura sans
doute que des cases pour revenir en jeu
et puis en plus on a isolé ce pion qui
deviennent faiblesse oui alors il a eu
peur de l'avancée du roi blanc des
quatre coins
voilà peut-être peur de ça mais là on
peut jouer recette est menacée soi même
de repousser le renoir
il ya cavaliers ou quatre qui la vallée
aux 4 quand même mais là on peut on peut
les changer ce cavalier là et le roi
prend et le plus bref cat est un peu le
pied en se fiant un peu faible
effectivement c'est comme ça qu'il l'a
pas fait mais ce qu'il a fait pire ce
qu'il a fait pire puisqu'ils jouent donc
f4 il joue f4 maintenant il est là il
n'a pas vu le coup suivant magnifique de
topalov regard des cavaliers 1,4 alors
ça c'est beau pourquoi vous aurez plus
le joueur b 5 aussi servait même on se
dit mais si c'est idiot puisque je perds
le fouet trois roues oui mais attention
parce que regarder
hop là tout est apple une attaque à la
découverte de la tour ses mythes et
voilà donc il ya une attaque
intermédiaires ont estimé ces paraphes
j'échange et après je prends le foudroie
donc ça permet gaz une pièce mais encore
un coup intermédiaire alors on voit le
coût d'un an et ils échangent
effectivement mais là regard des coûts
intermédiaires échec cavaliers
magnifiquement placés soit 6e travers
son genre et les magnifiques en place et
et sur roy 17
regardez maintenant simplement on prend
du fou on peut prendre du fou bilan de
l'opération un cavalier superbe frappe
pour les blancs alors que les noirs
on n'a rien obtenu alors on revient on
remonte la variante sur f4 ce que n'a
pas vu à nantes c'est ce fameux cavale
de quatre intermédiaires menace échec et
on peut par exemple y aurait pu aussi
jouer cavalier b5
on aurait pu jouer qu'avec les baies 5
bien sûr donc en fait ce qu'ils voient
par le cou qui voient ils voient pas la
menace car elle est desservie voit
peut-être pas le coup intermédiaire
l'échec même caillou 4 oui le menace
d'un faut absolument trouver quelque
chose alors donc ici il aurait dû
échanger des fous et ne pas hésiter à
faire ça alors bon bref f4 cac valeo 4
et tout repenser un câble et des six
échecs en l'endroit 17 fou prend c'est
un bilan des courses gros cavaliers
centrales ont déjà les blancs du fait
d'avoir ce groupe k valais central ici
on peut pas avec les noirs jouent et au
racing pour attaquer le pion aux
cavaliers évidemment un tacle à 4 5 1
les puissants puis surtout il ya des
menaces des chèques cadhoc découverte
encore et moi je veux prendre 17
mais surtout on a ce cas valeo 4 chèques
oui et on prend le fou mais c'est encore
qui doit encore jouer le roi c'est la
deuxième fois que le roi doit partir de
la colonne des ça fait deux fois donc ça
fait des coups de feu qu'il a été
constamment sur la défensive bon mais
alors dès lors si jolifou d2 simplement
un fou d2 lors pourquoi phobie de c'est
bien parce que d'abord sa les paul gray
la tour mais surtout on va sans doute
jouer ou c3 qui tiendra le pion à celle
le pion
1 sec le pion b2 qui va tout tenir
tranquille un des deux il continue de
viser le pion f4 aussi noir est faible
je continue à attaquer car je peux
envisager pourquoi pas d'être une chose
quoique il met sur wade 5 je peux jouer
pour ses sets je peux aussi sur la 7e
donc faut sept tours échec c'est ce qui
se passe d'ailleurs ici la sueur
évidemment voir des cinq la tour on
avait quand même tour c7 et surtout
prendre les six puis on prend des six
nations
roy prend des six ben je peux prendre 17
et je continue d'attaquer
oui le lendemain je savais qu'après
chèque aussi et je menace fourbe et
quatre échecs ramasse la tour f 8 sur
tours fc qui est une possibilité perd
1,6 et sa perf 4,7 ce qui a trait à 6 je
peux faire tomber 6 et rend la situation
encore mieux puisque là j'ai deux pions
passé lié après je vais plus sérieux on
pourra pas prendre à 6.6 et pardon mais
on va pouvoir prendre la solution va
faire échec francs à six et on a
maintenant passé les efforts
donc ça serait ça serait que perdre
enfin il doit toujours surveiller
l'entrée en effet voilà donc il faut
absolument protégera donc ça c'est
soutif un pur
vous exploitez la manger voilà pour
apprendre le jeu dès qu'il faut éviter
les tours en septième pour les blancs et
inversement quand on a les blancs que
les noirs viennent en deuxième rangée
puisqu'en général il ramasse beaucoup de
deux pions beaucoup de clopes il ya des
menaces des chèques aussi en général
très très très pénibles roi 17 donc fou
6 3 voilà ce qu'on avait dit donc en
fait un tour c'est en fait il a repoussé
le roi noir et maintenant je vous
faisais croire ou nous anime attention
parce que je vais prendre le cavalier et
et après je vais récupérer l'urne et 6
effectivement fou prend des six mais il
aurait pu reprendre d'ailleurs parce que
le roi - auraient peuple prendre
on aurait pu reprendre et sur roy prend
des six échecs ramasse la tour et fuite
mais ce qu'il a fait mieux parce que ça
lui laisse le choix ensuite de prendre
soin avec le pion soit avec notre tour d
un voile à tour d un jeu clou le four à
dire ça c'est magique on ne reprend pas
tout de suite on n'est pas obligé de
reprendre tout de suite aux échecs si
vous clouer des fois ça peut être
intéressant
en l'occurrence ici c'est intéressant et
on peut prendre soin du pion maintenant
soit de la tour bien sûr fou et 5 de la
part d'un monde donc ça alors ce coup
fou et 5
sans doute pour pouvoir jouer g5
protéger f4 libéré la tour tout
simplement parce que pour l'instant la
tourbe quand même vérifier ce pion qui à
tout moment peut être attaqué par par
tour des quatre plus tard par le fou qui
vient des deux donc qu'il faut quand
même commencer à prévoir de le protéger
par un pion alors à noter que ça sent
quand même des pions surnom de sur la
couleur du fou est pas terrible ça h4
s'explique le coût souvent de topalov il
empêche gsa c'est crucial oxygénation
je suis un homme pourquoi pas donc on
enlève le plonger cette de la prise du
fou de cases blanches et l'at on prend
des 6es oui il a préféré jouer avec une
tour active que reprendre tout de suite
avec le pion qui aurait bloqué sa tour d
un donc avec ça et là plus de mobilité
et puis maintenant l'objectif suivant de
topalov c'est le pion f4 evans déjà way
et pylônes il ya des problèmes du suroît
soir c'est là on peut jouer deux tours b
6 oui ou même fou b4 m'a l'air très fort
mais ouais ou des quatre tout de suite
qui menacent de sortir la tour avec
échec et on ramasse la tour derrière mme
est tombé 6 % sur tourbe évite
simplement je trouvais quatre échecs
suivi de fous des six la tour doit
bouger et je prends 17 alors à noter
quand même dans cette position que les
fous de couleurs opposées sont un
facteur annulant mais tant qu'ils
allaient tour s'est pas fait quoi ouais
donc tout reprend des six échecs dont
clara s'est vite alors là aussi je joue
pas c'est celle que j'aurais pu
envisager à cause sans doute de fous des
4 suivi de foot des six échecs et le roi
est pris dans une espèce de boîte 1
absolument il y aurait 1
menaces de maths qui prendrait au nez
des blancs des noirs une menace de ma
tante des huit kimo immobiliserait la
tour adler sur la sur la huitième manger
pour protéger puis un renoir qui serait
totalement le roi blanc au contraire
aurait une grande liberté de manoeuvre
pas du tout le roi noir donc fou des
deux ici topalov ici donc pourquoi ces
huit empêche cette manoeuvre donc ici
surtout des quatre on pourrait envisager
c'est un peu mon tour des huiles qui
échangent les tours et on l'a dit les
fous de couleurs opposées sont un
facteur annula on peut même donner un
pion dans ces cas là donc la regarder en
jouant h 4 on a privé le quai f4 d'une
défense donc fou des deux et on peut pas
protéger le plomb et 4 de façon vraiment
efficace si au lieu d'un oeil
il ya une autre possibilité au lieu de
fous des deux il aurait pu jouer tour
des quatre pour l'accueil qu'ils ont un
cap de cette façon alors peuvent pas
protéger ce pion puisque si on joue au
foot bien par exemple ici simplement fou
des deux mais il est permis
c'était peut-être un choix supérieur à
celui qui a fait topalov d'échanger les
tours de laisser échanger les tours 10
oui parce qu'en jouant soudée de tout de
suite au lieu de tour des quatre ça
permet une finale de fukui euros poser
sans détour
ça permet d'augmenter considérablement
les chances de nuages mais là il a vu
qu'il aurait un pion avancé en d6 il a
misé là dessus mais on va voir que en
fait allende avait là nul donc tour des
huit permet d'échanger les tours c'est
quand même mon entretien autour des 4
plus précis que fout des deux peut-être
peut-être ça reste à analyser en tout
cas c'est en plein ça que je reste à 100
dont ils ont joué ça a mené une finale
bien sûr des véhicules on peut prendre
de la tour et ça évite les changes de
tours et on peut se poursuivre par g4 on
peut créer des grosses menaces même
après de pénétrer henri vii
effectivement les taureaux puissante et
fous des deux permet tour des huit
essais difficile d'éviter l'échangé
autour parce que si on joue tourbe et 6
qui a le fou noir qui peut s'activer en
d3 alors on peut faire échec et on peut
aussi on peut faire du chelsea bien déjà
je pense qu'on peut jouer aussi tour des
5 et tour des quatre oui pour s'élever
au théâtre autour des 4 et 20 attention
il ya eu aussi ce qui enlève à le pion
aux six étant leur maison mais on peut
vous les contre-attaqués sur le pire aux
alors on toujours s'éclate aussi
peut-être tout simplement avait faussé
attention voilà donc j'essaie de
possibilité ou alors non tout simplement
tourner autour des cadres voilà hectares
d'ici là ça c'est bien puisque alors si
qu'est ce qui se passe là on peut pas
faire tourner les investissements là
donc c'est mieux faudra faire échec il
faut jouer autour des 4 on protège et on
protège f4 et c'est plus dur pour les
blancs là oui c'est plus dur donc ils
laissent s'échanger les tours parfaits
pour un f4 donc on prend le pire aux
indécis c'est prend le pion tôt pour
prendre et 6e prendrait six bilan des
courses les noms auraient réussi à
échanger les tours mais au prix d'un
pion et qu'elle pions un gros pions donc
ça semble difficile de tenir ce
une position comme ça avec un pion ces
avancées mais avec les fous couleurs
opposées voilà les chances 2 nuls on va
voir regardez ça veut dire les [ __ ]
que leur poser c'est qu'on a un fou ici
sur case noire et l'autre sur quatre ans
donc c'est fou ne se ne peuvent pas se
tâte hier que les noirs ils ont un
contrôle des cases blanches que les
blancs ont du mal à leur contester voilà
puisqu'ils n'ont ils ont caf ou des
cases noires on peut comprendre donc
souvent le jeu se bloque sur la couleur
du fou qu'on possède essais des noirs
même avec deux pions - par exemple 3 po
- parfois arrivent à annuler parce
qu'ils bloquent les le jeu sur la voie
de la bouger si l'idée qu'on bouge enfin
il ya mon nom peut plus bouger parce que
le roi adverse et le fou empêche de
bouger sur 15 blanche
on n'arrive pas à intervenir sur les
cases de la couleur que contrôler
l'adversaire parce qu'on n'a pas assez
de forces pour ça on n'a que le roi qui
tous les pions voilà on n'est pas le
fouet et à l'inde a très bien joué cette
finale
oui il va très très bien joué mais au
prix d'un long et fort il va même passer
beaucoup de temps de réflexion
et finalement il va craquer on va voir
ça donc il joue wade s'est donc déjà
envoyé mais aurait omis les pions l est
les rois et sur 15 blanche et où on voit
qu'avec le font pour rien faire alors
maintenant l'objectif d'otor palox et
d'aller prendre le pion à vii avec son
roi voilà si la voilà si là il apprendre
ce pion il a déjà une qui ont passé ici
qui donc bloc soit le roi soit le fou si
là il va prendre ce pion h7 il aura un
deuxième puis on passe et il va pouvoir
jouer en 4 h 5 et donc se créer un
deuxième pion de passer et là le roi va
pouvoir aider et le foot seule ne pourra
pas empêcher
si par contre ses pions reste ça va être
on peut pas passer on n'a pas de deux
on n'a qu'une seule faiblesse entre
guillemets alors en fait et maintenant
pour à l'envi retenu en reste et le roi
de topalov avec son propre droit mais
surveillez le pion avancé des six avec
le fou c'est ça qui va s'escrimer à
faire il va réussir à ses biens dans les
coups qui suivent alors on va voir à
rocroi de trois fous ces deux on va voir
comment ça se passe donc ici regardez
topaloff
ils essayent de s'infiltrer alors
attention parce que si roy s'il arrive
si le roi ici ça va être ça risque
d'être vite pénible
pour après roger 7 donc remis leurs amis
voilà j'empêche le roi de passer voir si
les blancs maintenant poussent leurs
pions 17 c'est pas bon parce que le roi
noir vient le canal de là je prends
alors là du coup c'est moins grave si
gmt au moins de ce côté là puisque j'ai
éliminé le deuxième principal danger
voilà le principal danger voilà donc
issifou 3 voilà on regarde et maintenant
donc le roi est passé là on bloque
maintenant l'avancé du pions blancs avec
l'autre pièce donc c'est soit le roi qui
protège d'un côté le fou soit les bears
en suivant où le roi noir va essayer
comme un gardien de but l'a25
industralisés l'avant-centre en restant
devant voilà alors suivi les coûts le
repousse tous à l'euro à l'avoir bien
attaque du pion donc la regarde et on
bien la regarder voyez qu'on peut pas
passer et que le fou est pas le foot
qu'à zone noire il tape dans le vélo ita
dans le vide et c'est très difficile de
passer acheter bon ben il essaie de
provoquer g prend h5 voir ici menace
évidemment alors attention parce que sur
un coup comme fou et 8 ici ce serait une
erreur la cci losc il a joué 8 annoncés
par la suite ce n'est pas une avoir tout
de suite non mais
non ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il faut
éviter à changer si ça je prends
reprendrait le deuxième pion que j'ai
passée donc il faut 8 et forcé en fait
non il pouvait aussi prendre à te
prendra 5 du monde va le rappeler se
réfère plus tard voilà roi f7 oil 6
maintenant il prend c'est un projet 5
oui parce que là ce roi g5 qui menacent
d'aller en rave six classes et alors ils
menacés à d'ailleurs que la partie s'est
terminée sur la côte il arrive à aller
en effet sicilien f6 regarde ses yeux il
ya en recettes après le pion épouse
imaginons que les noirs ne jouent par 17
il laisse ouvert maintenant je suis pas
fou 17 mai à dire fou 17 à faire des
ronds f6 et là c'est très dur
pourquoi parce que la menace parce
qu'après six îles féroé fuite il joue
foule 3,6 et jacques de la menace est
roi des scènes et je le fais dame donc
choisi de sacrifier le faut il oblige
roi et fuite dont croyais fuite et forcé
elle a d'ailleurs c'est un peu un 12 ans
ont peu joué par exemple le détroit où
b4g p4 paris là il n'a pas de coût
valable si j'ouvre le 8 et enragé set et
là ça y est je prends de l'autre côté et
s'il enlève le fou évidemment il ya des
cet échec s'il enlève le fou il ya des
cet échec
imaginez-vous essec regarder une photo
d'un échec du fou et on peut pas revenir
en 8es et donc après je fais dames avec
échec en plus et même matin donc le roi
noir essaye de neutraliser le roi blanc
grèce devant la france est celle que
l'opposition elle a exactement les
pénétrer donc échecs pour essayer de le
déloger
mais voilà je n'ai pas le choix je
devenir un f-16 sinon ça permet
réussissent aussi est donc là il a joué
un petit coup de prévention fou et 5
pour bloquer le pied aussi s'il n'a pas
voulu que les noirs se libèrent des
diagonales
il n'a pas envie que il
augmenterait l'activité du fou noir
c'est tout à fait don qui le
neutralisent en faux 16 d'emploi pense
que là les noirs n'ont pas de coût si si
j'enlève le roi sirois m6 oui c'est ça
donc il a donné h théâtre ça c'était bon
il a très très bien joué à nantes
jusqu'à présent angers si ce n'est pas
la mienne est un peu de terrain droit g4
c'est normal qu'à aller vers la gauche
éventuellement fourbe et 5 voilà
j'essaie de devenir attaqué par
l'arrière pourquoi pas oui et puis bon
il reste en défense du pion avancé des
six faut que je garde un oeil sur 17
voisins et ça c'est très important au f4
alors là ils reculent pourquoi parceque
il a peur que le roi blanc passe à 4 c 5
le cadre c'est la taille 5 et 7 et hop
et après je pousse donc ils doivent
cette fois là commencé à aller un peu à
gauche si le roi va à gauche c'est le
rouleau suis jamais eu droit et si les
blancs de pouce de côté c'est le fou qui
ce genre roi noir doit toujours
surveiller les mouvements du roi blanc
lé en bougeant lui-même vous mettre en
face au mur d'en face 3g 5 pouces et
voilà c'est là un moment dramatique
alors pourquoi erreur plats qui sont
qu'est ce qu'ils auraient dû jouer là il
aurait dû jouer food et 3 pour défendre
le pion à vii avec son fou voilà pour
défendre et rester avec son roi où il
est et avait le roi soit resté là sur le
soin les uns des soldes et cette voix là
et là les blancs peuvent pas mais on
laisse kashi le roi noir c'est fini
parce que dès qu'on regarde et il n'y a
pas de moyen de passer quoi ces sections
difficile phase ils ont fait chou blanc
toujours g4 f4 f5
oui mais à ce moment là on échangera
l'on joue à roye 8 0 17
on peut voilà donc ici par exemple
imaginons que vous les blancs jouent on
va essayer de voir sa non par exemple ça
on croit 8 f4 il reviendra
décès parce qu'il faut bloquer ce pion
et sur f5 simplement on prend on est
obligé de reprendre pied là on attend et
que vous et là on peut même faire une
chaîne et oui aussi mais on peut mieux
faire et où ferme on attend on attend et
il n'y a pas de coup c'est ça on
pourrait certes parce que si on bouge là
le roi pas de casque s'il bouge le fou
prend l'opinion donc ici on pousse à
bassam e anniversaire voici maintenant
paroisse aussi facile lui peut aussi
mais il peut aussi éminent de la russie
salle en fout aussi vous g6 fou g6 voilà
red hat en rouge et si si regardez le le
le laurent blanc mais s'il vient à 1 h 6
on attend sur les cases blanches g7 en
vers le haut 6e 8 6 3 8
attention il y aura quand même des 17 ya
des choses qu en mai et h5 voilà il ya
aprilia h5 qui est possible voilà enfin
en tout cas c'est une défense masse a
bloqué tout ça c'était un monde a admis
que c'était son erreur tout ceci est
faux c'est 6 alors pourquoi parce que
croatie voilà alors voilà rejoint 18 g4
à bandeau voilà parce que alors abandon
il a abandonné trop vite pour les
spectateurs qui comprend le pion alors
non parce que le pur des six vadam
immédiatement ça c'est que les 7 et
d'accorder ce qu il a abandonné parce
qu'il ya un plan imparable pour the wall
of donc si par exemple il avait joué un
coup d'attentes mais attention c'est
votre page où le roi kohei 3.716 l'avait
juifs ou 17 ans faut jouer le plus
d'attentes alors par exemple sous 17 ont
joué ou g5 a très bien donc là je sais
maintenant il joue fous ces 6 revient
par exemple la haye le couple est
maintenant c'est fou g7 où j'ai cette
fois là il nous en disant qu'il a il
attend alors il faut jouer encore un
coup d'attendre
bref le v5 ou là on va voir que si je
vous invite en fait on peut le forcer à
faire un coût d'attenté ensuite avec le
mais là on gagne par g6 a g6 maintenant
h projet 6 obligé pour apprendre à voir
blanc passe en recettes et en à venir
est imparable bras
alors si si les noirs avaient joué la
fois au but il avait fait 800 faisait un
coup d'attentes vous évite par exemple
on joue f4 par exemple parce que là il
ya eu besoin le roi peut pas bouger
voilà ça problème jouer à quatre où on a
encore plein kouamé le pion et là on
nous oblige à rejouer à se regarder s'il
aura bouge on perd h7 saint-jude zinc un
exemple c'est à dire le meilleur coût
serait de ne pas jouer ouais c'est
interdit aux échecs avec vous jouez donc
ige dire fou 17.2 c'est fait maintenant
à la saucisse et après je prends voix
prend regarder le roi noir qui est
bloqué et on a joué roi la suivent héros
dans cette force à d'abord relevé le fou
en bien sûr bien sûr alors mais on peut
imaginer d'autres coûts et donc foule a
ses forces et voilà fou
ici oui voilà où je vous fais si on joue
d'abord fort et gentil au risque alors
enfin on peut aussi d'ailleurs joué
heureuse c'était gagnant mais marina
faut joindre coup là voilà ici donc fou
h6 et là on peut pas empêcher on va
regarder le roi ne peut pas passer à
cause du foot alors sur wells 7 la
foulée cinq souffre ou g5 et on ne peut
pas empêcher 3e set suivi de 17
on doit sacrifier le fou et ça une fois
c'est la suite gagne facilement le roi
ramasse tous les pions et les pions fils
adam ya plus rien à faire et je vous lis
donc grosses erreurs ici et voilà sera
acté c'est vraiment de la fatigue
alors que fout des trois tiens j'imagine
mal topalov faire le jeu en ce genre
d'erreur au détroit ce que topalov
fatigue moins vite qu'un an
on va revoir quand même la possibilité
qu'il aurait pu faire ici alors voir ici
par exemple dans dix-sept élèves pilotes
f4 donc là des coudes attend non mais il
peut même faire et c'est fou de vous
voilà donc sa force
j'ai 5 voilà et la tour eiffel on peut
plus bouger c'est là la fameuse regarder
grâce aux pions et des du fou voilà on
tient tout on se contente de bouger de
fou sur la diagonale bhc on peut pas
bouger les pions ils sont gobé par le
fou ils sont ils et qui sera protégé par
les pions c'est comme ça qu'on fait nul
dans les finales et finalement des bouts
de chou exactement belle partie garde à
nantes quand même dans peut-être c'est
ça c'est ce que tu disais au début oui
là c'est vraiment la gaffe par fatigue
ils en sont à ce moment là au 55e coup
54e coup et topalov que j'imagine dans
la même situation lors elle n'aurait
jamais fait ce genre en vogue
est ce que ça pourrait trouver un manque
de préparation du coup physique d'un an
de kiki qui du coup bah c'est pas
préparation c'est physiquement il est
moins fort nettement mais ça on
s'entraîne physiquement pas encore
rattrape pas 30 ans dans la salle lauga
bougies non il a innové relativement
saine mais je n'y étais pas un sportif
en boîte ben c'est pas un sportif alors
que topaloff
on voit clairement que c'est un athlète
belle victoire de topalov qui revient
dans le match
égalité après cette huitième partie
reste qu'à tard il devient il devient
favori des favoris alors je vous chez
lui il faut vous faut pas oublier
peut-être on peut revenir en plateau sur
la régie puisqu'on a fini ce commentaire
de partie alors
effectivement quand on parle of alors
plus frais sur la fin ils jouent chez
riot sommes tous impliqués on suppose
que les médias sont dessus là bas de
façon intensive aussi bon marque
allemande est pas obligé de la télé car
non plus mais là le problème aussi c'est
un peu comme au football quand on rentre
dans les dix dernières minutes
celui qui va même d'en gagner une partie
va quasiment gagné le match parce que
oui c'est très très difficile sur
commande pour la non mais attendez
oui enfin si l'asie il ya bien sûr une
carpe ou afghanes l'avant dernière haie
et kasparov doit gagner la dernière il y
arriver car offs et kasparov oui c'est
vrai il est bon je pense que quand même
sans injurier attendait topalov ils sont
d'un niveau un peu en dessous de
kasparov
lisons ducasse par offre des années 90
90 mais ce qui compte c'est la
différence de niveau entre les deux bien
sûr oui alors on va rappeler merci
nicolas pour nous avoir accompagnés sur
cette huitième partie je vous rappelle
alors le magnifique nouveau guide des
échecs traité complet chez laffont dans
toutes les bonnes librairies toute
l'histoire du jeu d'échecs les partis
gagnants du championnat du monde
un quart du livre aussi consacré à des
magnifiques problème alors en plus c'est
un livre comme tu dis qui tient la main
il tient il tient sur la table quand on
le pose 10 restent ouverts donc ils se
referment pas toute la collection
bouquins cette particulière la paix
1 et toute l'histoire de la vie et puis
et puis toutes les règles du jeu un du
déplacement des pièces aux règles du
rock les règles de promotion etc
c'est je vais vous dire c'est la bible
des échecs en français il ya vraiment
tout et puis vous avez le plaisir
d'avoir nicolas giffard la maison
évidemment le plus grand écrivain
français d'échec des temps modernes
double champion de france et même
internationale ici c'est nicolas magic
giffard qu'on appelle sur la gonade tv
acheter le nouveau guide des échecs
voilà merci de nous suivre sur la webtv
ne nous est fidèle qui vous donne rendez
vous pour la suite de ce magnifique
championnat du monde à nantes
topalov au revoir